[Music]
I could not live a day without going to see
the vultures, it
has been my university throughout the
40 years that we have been bringing food
here to the vultures, this vulture thing
is my passion
[Music]
my name is manuel aguilera sanz  and I am an
ornithology guide I
was nine years old the first time I
saw a griffon vulture when my grandfather took me
to the dunghill
I was fascinated and impressed and at
12 years old I was going alone to the dunghill to
see them and since then well until
now I have been  always studying them
because there was very little written
and I wanted to be close to them to
learn more
so I would take the carcass of another
animal and get inside its
ribs with a small
field notebook and when the vultures came down to
eat I had them  by my side how are you
here
[Music]
well this is very useful today for
future biology students and all
this world that take advantage of my my
data on the evolution of birds
I have a small group of some  20 or so vultures
that have older names
run run has been with me for over 25 years they are
a little older their behavior is
different in each individual and in this
I immediately know
whitten they have to live in colonies in
large groups a vulture or two alone do not
live  if these colonies go down a lot they
are in danger
if there are no people who care about
them because they will disappear and future
generations will not be able to see them there are nine
subspecies in the world and one of them
is the chip filmus conservation
has to be here on earth twitter
It has always been seen as something
that swims, that is a vermin, or a little less
kalimán, and in many people it
is difficult to change the chip of an elderly person,
groups of people from
all over the world arrive here, groups are not organized
that bring them here to  see the vultures and they
arrive here with the mentality that
these vultures are going to attack them and
eat them when they leave here they leave
with another chip
I wait for when I die  For them to take me
like all the beings they have taken,
I only hope that there is no more I don't care
[Music]